in the previous exercise we have
constructed the matrix table for all the
data that's required for our study in
this exercise here what I'm going to
show you is how to normalize the the row
count into a C score which will allow us
to compare across all the different cell
lines
for the normalization we need to
specific software one of it is our
program version two point nine point
zero another one is the shrnas ik
algorithm now it is important that the
are programmed version two point nine
point zero is required and the other
later version might not work because sh
rnaseq was written using the are two
point nine point zero version of our
program so you can download this
software in the link that is provided
here and install into the program so
once you have installed then I will show
you how you can actually format it a
that it does that and to perform the
normalization
okay so to install e to find the our two
point nine point zero you can go to this
link here so which will lead you to the
page that looked like this basically now
so the current bush okay the current
version is actually quite advanced I
think is the are three point five point
zero so but what we need is basically we
want to go to the older version which
you can click here so you can click by
this link here we should lead you to the
archive so how the version that we won
is two point nine point zero so you can
go down here the least and then went to
point nine point zero which will be here
and then when you click this link that
it will automatically download into your
download folder all you need to do is
that you extract it and then you can
install it into your you know test your
your computer and you can also similarly
okay download the algorithm for the
shrna stick using this this link here so
once it is downloaded so your file would
actually locate it in the C Drive under
the program X is six and then you can go
to the our folder here so now you see
the folder with our two point nine point
zero and then if you go in there and you
go into the library folder that is where
you would be able to find the shrna sic
library
so once you have downloaded and install
the software that is required you can
refer to the words document which I have
already uploaded to the to the Dropbox
the name of the file is called and
implies analysis the 20 1804 3-0 here
you will get a more specific instruction
on how to run the analysis and also the
command for the are so of notice that
while this is the our program it is a
slightly different than the a switch
which we look which we use in the
previous exercise so what we need to do
here is basically we need to process ok
the information or the data from the
matrix table in a specific format so
that the SH rnaseq can actually read it
so if you want to access how all those
how the format can be done you can go in
here so under your Program Files ok our
are point to point nine point zero and
then library and then under the shrna
say there will be a folder on data so
under the data you have okay
one is the SH RNA library if you open
this up this is basically the file that
will tell you about the notation that
you need to put in for your SH our RNA I
will show you how to construct that
later on and you also have a file which
is coffee no data then you have to file
ok which labels mcf7 liability time one
and two so we will stick to the same
format okay by changing just the data
inside it to avoid any complication so
in the next few slides and the video I'm
going to show you how you are going to
construct each of this file for your
analysis
okay so to construct the input file
there's a few things that we need to put
in mind okay the effect protocol was
actually written in this verse document
now first of all they are the four files
that we need to construct one of it as a
Charney library and we did shrna library
you must have the columns on reference
pool target six simple and also Church
in description now for fie not data okay
we will remain as it is we wouldn't do
much of the changes and also for mcf-7
by the time one okay we will also use
back the same file name because all the
script the our script that is written
was actually refer to specific found him
so in that case we would try to change
as little or probablistic to whatever
found name and also the output that is
so to minimize the changes in terms of
the screen so to show you how we can do
it it's basically the first thing is
that well for certain reason the SH
rnaseq would not be able to recognize
the number under the so called reference
column so to do that what I'm going to
do is I need to create a few more column
and also rename a field so first of all
the first column shrna ID I will change
it to reference basically so okay I'm
just going to rename the date column and
then the other one I will so okay the
pool now I'm going to insert another
column here okay call pool okay and then
the target sequence okay simple and no
search in description respectively so
here you go so that is what we will
create a column now at the pool here we
will assume that it is just from one
pool I'm sorry
so okay or copy all the way down so this
will be all assumed as a single pool all
right
this one here now as I mentioned it
before
okay the reference we need to create
this more of a text so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to add at the front of
the number with a few an alphabet so in
this case here I will use the
concatenate formula so by taking TRC in
front followed by the number there you
go so you can see that now I'm going to
change it here like this I'm going to
copy this whole column and then paste it
as text over here okay so I can delete
this column okay so you see that what we
have I have now modified the a matrix
table slightly different to suit for the
shrna library sick input file
okay before we move on to the next dish
to create a input file note that some of
the gene symbol have a comma with a
different alternative name as well now
this well to avoid some of the problem
in the downstream so basically what we
are going to do is we are going to use
create only one input for each of the
gene name by removing the rest of the
alternative gene name so what we are
going to do is we are going to copy the
whole the whole column the whole column
here and then we are going to separate
them by okay text to column we are going
to separate them by comma okay so now
here you go so this now is all separator
and then we will copy this file back to
the original and then this is page and
then paste it as well as tags so now
that you have metrics that that is more
suitable for the input into the SH
rnaseq
okay now to create an input file what
I'm going to do is I'm going to copy
okay on this column and I'm going to
create 4px pc3 for example the input
file I'm going to paste it into an
separate sheet so I can remove this top
column here and now the next thing what
I need to do is busy I need to remove
those with the zero count because the SH
rnaseq would return an error when it
encountered a zero count here so
basically from both the plasmid and also
the sample count
whichever column that I have the zero I
need to remove them together basically
this these are all the one or the row
with the zero counter I'm going to
delete the row okay so and again I'm
going to do the same as well for the
sample count here so to remove all those
if the zero okay if you do not remove
the zero count entry so the SH rnaseq
will not be able to proceed basically
okay so now that is all deleted
basically now okay I'm going to copy the
first few columns okay and then paste it
into the shrna library file here which
is a text format okay so now it's
important is that this is on a library a
notation must match with the input that
I'm going to put in for both the control
and also the treated cells so I'm going
to save this now I'm going to create
another few more columns I'm going to
create one column here this is reference
and then again so for each of the input
file you must have a column for
reference track one and also rap too I'm
going to create a rap one and then rap
two here okay so
the control so this is the data from the
control since the data set only have
there's no replication I will put okay I
will input the same value into the wrap
too as well so this these three columns
would then represent the control or the
plasmid sample count and I will create
another few more row okay
now this one will be for the sample
count so again I will copy and paste it
here okay so for the control I'm going
to copy the whole dataset and then paste
it into the mcf-7 white time one here
basically just going to copy and paste
it here okay let's save and then for
time too so I'm going to copy and paste
the the sample count here okay okay so
now okay
we've touched so we did not harsh of no
deputy not touch the final data file
here so we will leave it as it is so the
rate the improve our should be ready to
proceed with the shrna algorithm now
okay so now the other input file is
ready we will open the our program and
the script now to get the exact script
again you can refer back to the word
documents here so if you do not change
all the filenames and anything so all
you can do is that you can actually copy
and paste a whole script and it will run
it automatically so okay now let's see
if we copy the whole script here and I'm
going to put it paste it into the are
here basically now then it will take a
while so basically it will run this
script by script okay each line by line
okay we will wait for it to process
you
okay we show you some graph here now for
the detail of how to interpret the graph
that is shown here you can actually
refer to this paper okay which is
actually by seem at all in genome
pathology
this was a paper that was described okay
how the SAR Nasik work and and so forth
the algorithm and what does it mean in
terms of the data in the graph so I will
leave you to it's good that you read
through it and understand the principle
behind it but to cut short of our
discussion basically if you see here is
that while the report is actually
reported in automatically reported into
the C Drive okay users and whatever
users name that you log on to and under
the documents so you can actually here
basically you can what we called it
while you can actually retrieve the
report from the My Documents folder here
and when you open it up so and this is
the the normalize data that you will get
you can copy this and then you can paste
it into an excel file if you want to now
but if you do that you will get a lot of
the data which look like this so all you
need to do is basically just text to
column and then convert use the tab
telling delimiters to actually generate
into each of the columns okay so now
that you can see that okay so this is
the reference okay this is a target
sequencing simple this is the original
data that you input it in and then there
is a few columns in terms of
normalization and the most important
thing that we will be looking at is
actually this column here quarter score
now if you refer back to the sims at our
paper
the score is basically referred to the z
score and we and we will actually use
this z score okay for the subsequent and
that it is okay with RSA and also rigor
you can repeat this whole process okay
with each of the cell lines and
then once we are done then we can
compare the z-score for each cell lines
okay and then we can perform for the
test from there onwards that's it for
now
you